thank you so much it's such an honor to
be with you and an honor to be invited
to return here to this city and to give
this address to the Nobel Peace Prize
forum
I want to thank Olaf Neos Todd the Nobel
Institute director Servine Stirling the
rector of the University of Oslo Raymond
Johansen the governing mayor of Oslo
leave a tortoise of the Nobel Institute
of Peace Center and I wish to
acknowledge as a group the members of
the Norwegian Nobel Committee and I wish
to congratulate the committee on their
wise choice that led to yesterday's
inspiring ceremony it was a magnificent
statement that the world must not only
recognize but accept global
responsibility for ending sexual
violence and sexual violence as an
instrument of war
Nadia Murad and Denis mukwege II are
such inspiring individuals these issues
must receive not only global attention
but determined follow-up the committee
has played a unique role in focusing the
world's attention on matters of
conscience on matters of security on
matters that affect the human future for
many years until the change was made in
1990 the ceremony took place in this
magnificent hall but as the prominence
of the committee's judgment and the
significance of the award grew over the
years that naturally the audience grew
and it was moved in to City Hall I
remember so vividly 11 years ago it was
the greatest honor of my life of course
to receive the award in tandem with the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change some members of the IPCC are here
and I very much look forward to the
discussion of the distinguished panel
after these remarks and then I look
forward to joining a whole tour for an
interview on stage after that in 2007 I
returned from Oslo I went to Bali for
the climate negotiations that were then
underway and tonight I will leave for
kata Vijay where the negotiations for
this year's conference of the parties
are underway but when I finally returned
back to my home in Tennessee where I
live in the city of Nashville but spend
a great deal of time on my farm 50 miles
away in the small town of Carthage where
I grew up it has only 2,000 people but
it was very proud in 1945 when one of
its residents its most distinguished
resident Cordell Hall received the Nobel
Peace Prize and was described by
President Franklin Delano Roosevelt as
the father of the United Nations he was
the author of the general agreement on
trade and tariffs he sponsored the
constitutional amendment creating an
income tax in the US and the early part
of the 20th century and the small
newspaper that serves the 2,000 people
of Carthage Tennessee put my the honor I
had received here in Oslo in perspective
for me with the headline on the front
page that
that Gore wins same prize Hall won
I want to say one more word about the
IPCC it was just insulted really by the
governments of the United States and
Saudi Arabia and Russia because when the
governments were called upon to welcome
the latest report of the IPCC two days
ago those three nations along with
Kuwait refused to do so and because the
body that governs the climate
negotiations operates by consensus they
were not able to welcome the report it
was for the three largest producers of
petroleum on the planet to choose a word
inconvenient to welcome the actual
scientific facts so I thought this might
be an appropriate occasion to take stock
of the big changes that have occurred
over these last 11 years the first
change is that the crisis the climate
crisis is growing worse rapidly and it
is growing worse more rapidly than the
world is developing and implementing
solutions we have what can only be
described as a global emergency
the phrase all-hands-on-deck applies
every nation every business every city
and regional government every civic
organization should be mobilizing
urgently to radically reduce the
emissions of manmade heat-trapping
global warming pollution I will turn to
the good news in a moment a preview is
that the second big change has been the
surprising emergence of solutions that
are available but I want to spend a few
more moments on the fact that it the
crisis is growing worse outside of the
door to this building there is a
demonstration of what one ton of co2
looks like we all saw it coming into the
building imagine 110 million of those
tons being released into the atmosphere
every 24 hours you don't have to imagine
that is what we are doing that is what
we will do again today and there is a
common misperception of the true nature
of the sky into which these 110 million
tons our daily spewed it is not the vast
and limitless expanse that appears to
our eyes as we stand on the ground and
look up at it and wonder it is in fact a
very thin shell of atmosphere
surrounding the planet the late Carl
Sagan used to say if you had a large
globe
with a coat of varnish the thickness of
that varnish relative to the globe is
equivalent to the thinness of the
atmosphere that surrounds our planet 110
million tons of manmade heat trapping
global warming pollution added to that
thin shell every single day day in and
day out mounts up and the molecules stay
there for a very long time some say a
thousand years but they say that because
the mathematics are complicated and a
certain percentage falls out sooner than
that a tiny percentage stays longer than
that but think of its residence time as
a thousand years the cumulative amount
in the atmosphere today traps as much
extra heat energy in the Earth's system
as would be released by five hundred
thousand Hiroshima class atomic bombs
exploding every day hard to imagine that
amount of energy it's a big planet on
which we live but that's an
extraordinary amount of heat energy and
it is radically changing the climate
balance the water cycle the fate of
living species on this earth the course
of human civilization and humanity's
future as a species the evidence is very
clear and indeed some of the evidence is
being delivered to us by Mother Nature
the scientists have renewed their
warnings in ever more urgent language in
the report that was not officially
welcomed in Poland
the scientists in the United States have
just completed the US National Climate
Assessment the global carbon project
just released its report on emissions
that deliver the disturbing news that
after three years of stabilized
emissions this this year they reported
on the first nine months there has been
a two point seven percent increase
following a 1.6 percent increase last
year but the messages from Mother Nature
may have more impact ninety-three
percent of all that extra heat energy is
going into the oceans and the oceans are
reflecting it back at us in the form of
much stronger and more destructive
cyclonic storms hurricanes typhoons as
well as cyclones all the same phenomena
with different names and different ocean
basins we are seeing wildfires like the
ones in California in the American West
this year the fire season has increased
by 105 days per year there were fires
here in Scandinavia this year in fact
six of the fires in Sweden were north of
the Arctic Circle there were fires in
many places because the same extra heat
that warms the oceans also warms the
land and dries the land out and as I
mentioned the water cycle is disrupted
because the amount of water vapor that
comes off the oceans increases as the
temperatures of the ocean increase that
water vapor is carried by atmospheric
river
that are often 30 times larger than the
Mississippi River the largest in North
America and when it comes over the land
and encounters meteorological conditions
that trigger a downpour the downpours
are much larger rain bombs is the phrase
some meteorologists are using now and
they lead to much more destructive
floods and mudslides and the combination
of disruptive changes in the
precipitation patterns punctuated by
longer more severe periods of drought
his disrupting agriculture and
disrupting other important human
activities the increase in temperatures
themselves have an impact this year will
be among the fifth hottest years in
history the four hottest were the last
four 17 of the 18 hottest have been in
the last 18 years I was in Finland two
weeks ago and during the extraordinary
heat spell in Finland this summer many
people went to the local grocery stores
to lie in the aisles near the cooling of
the dairy products and the grocers were
very kind to allow them to make camp
there each night I could give many more
examples but the examples that come from
developing countries are ones that
should capture our attention the heat is
now combining with higher humidity which
on a global average has increased 5% in
the last 30 years to create a eat index
or a feels like temperature that is
close to exceeding
the boundaries of conditions in which
human beings can live in several
locations in the Middle East and North
Africa the combination of heat and
humidity has already at Posada cailli
exceeded 74 degrees no human being can
live outdoors for more than a few hours
in such conditions and we learned from
the scientists who specialize in these
matters
that large areas of the Middle East and
North Africa some parts of India some
parts of China some parts of Central
America may become functionally
uninhabitable the word is worth
repeating uninhabitable when an area
becomes uninhabitable the people who are
living there leave and they seek shelter
elsewhere there are more refugees in the
world today than at any time since the
immediate aftermath of world war two and
there are many causes for the flows of
refugees civil wars and violence the
kind of violence in the Congo that was
discussed earlier and yesterday but it
is abundantly clear that the fastest
growing cause of refugees is the climate
crisis in Syria for example long before
the civil war broke out in Syria and
opened the gates of hell the worst
droughts a climate related drought the
worst droughts in the 900 years of
record-keeping in the eastern
Mediterranean killed 80% of the goats
and other livestock in Syria destroyed
60% of the farms
and drove one-and-a-half million climate
refugees into the cities of Syria
causing the ministers of that country in
conversations reported through the
WikiLeaks mechanism I hate to mention
their name but printed some interesting
information and the Syrian Ministers
said before the Civil War we cannot
handle this all hell is going to break
loose and the civil war started soon
thereafter most of the refugees went to
neighboring countries and they have
borne that burden with dignity and
fortitude but the minor share came to
Europe and contributed along with other
factors to the growing wave of populist
authoritarianism even the drama
unfolding in London this week has a
connection one of the two most powerful
billboards installed by the pro brexit
forces showed an endless line of
refugees obviously from the Middle East
and North Africa heading toward the
borders of Europe and the slogan was the
EU has failed us all in my country and
the elections just passed president
Trump attempted to make a huge issue of
the so-called caravan of migrants from
Central America to the borders of the US
where they sought to request asylum and
in several interviews with these
migrants they said we're fleeing
violence but the story is more
complicated the isthmus of Central
America is perhaps the most vulnerable
geography in the world to the climate
crisis indeed there is an annual
vulnerability climate vulnerability
index and this year number one on the
list is the nation of Honduras number
five out of 140 at 184 Nations is
Guatemala the dry corridor that covers
parts of five countries in Central
America is the region from which these
refugees are leaving many of these
families have not had a harvest in over
a year some in two years they're hungry
and the predictions are that many
millions of others will be driven by
these new climate conditions to leave
the lands their ancestors have always
called home the destabilizing impact of
these climate refugees for the stability
of political systems in the world has
not been featured very frequently and
the analyses of the dangers associated
with the climate crisis but they do
impose a threat to global security there
are many other consequences which I
won't take the time to elaborate but
studies just in the last few weeks have
highlighted the growing rate of ice loss
in both Greenland and Antarctica and
Antarctica with areas of East Antarctica
long thought to be safely stable now
added to West Antarctica as a source of
sea level rise we are a coastal species
in the main and the number of cities and
islands and towns and low-lying areas
like the Bangladesh Delta that will
suffer tragedies as a result of sea
level rise
is a long list tropical diseases are
moving and biologists will alert us to
their strong belief that by far the most
serious consequence of the climate
crisis is the loss of biodiversity we
have already seen in the last few
decades the loss of half of all the
animals on this planet not species half
of all the animals gone we now face the
risk of half of all the living species
disappearing by the end of this century
how do we receive that news what sense
of moral responsibility do we feel when
faced with the news that on our watch
those of us alive during this moment
when the hinge of history is swinging
well perhaps if there was an organized
campaign to cast doubt on the truth of
the scientists work we would not have to
even think about shouldering
responsibility that's what's been going
on that's what's going on in Poland
today and this week it is a disgrace and
the judgment of history will be
extremely harsh of course but we can't
wait for history's judgment because we
have urgent business before us all of us
that brings me to the second of these
two big changes in the last 11 years we
have the solutions available it is
actually stunning
to take stock of how quickly the price
of renewable energy has plummeted some
of us were startled when computer chips
came down in price at a rate that no one
could have imagined was possible mobile
telephones flat-screen TVs the list is a
long one and some areas of technology we
now realize follow rules that are
different from those that govern the
Industrial Age things get cheaper and
better quickly and the good news is that
has happened with renewable energy it is
happening now with batteries it has
happened with LED light bulbs the prices
declined 94% just in less than 10 years
it's happening with green buildings it
must happen as well with sustainable
forestry and sustainable agriculture
we must recarbanation and we must
recognize that the best technology we
know of to remove co2 from the
atmosphere is called a tree and when
that technology is taken to scale it is
called a forest and we can hope that
clever scientists and technologists and
engineers will come up with new devices
that could actually remove the co2 from
the atmosphere with efficiencies that
exceed that of trees and forests but we
can't wait and yet we're losing one
football fields worth of forests every
second worldwide and the wave of
populist authoritarianism that I
referred to earlier has now spread to
Brazil with feared consequences
for the Amazon in any case we do have
solutions available to us today they can
be implemented they are being
implemented in my country the
fastest-growing job is solar installer
those jobs are growing nine times faster
than other jobs in the US economy in
fact the famous coal Museum in Kentucky
just installed solar panels on its roof
to save money for its annual operating
budget the second fastest growing job is
wind turbine technician it seems obvious
to me and to some others that the world
is now in the early stages of a
sustainability revolution based in part
on the new digital tools of the Internet
of Things and machine learning and
artificial intelligence and a host of
other technologies giving executive
teams and business and industry the
ability to handle electrons and atoms
and molecules and cells and genes with
the same precision the IT businesses
have demonstrated in their skill at
managing bits of information and we see
these changes sweeping the global
economy we need a circular economy
because in addition to the two
transforming agriculture and forestry we
have to transform industry with circular
supply loops that reuse waste and it's
not impossible to do all of these are
changes that will benefit humanity in
multiple ways aside from saving our
future we can use it to create
employment at a time when the secular
economy needs
increased demand investors are helping
to lead the way as well and I wish to
acknowledge the presence in this
audience of English links Todd from the
Norwegian Bank and the presence of a
good many other investors who have
integrated sustainability into their
investment models I hope that the nation
of Norway will recognize what I regard
as the wisdom of the Norwegian Bank in
proposing a 100% divestment from all oil
and gas assets I know it's a difficult
choice but it's a smart financial choice
as well as a moral and ethical choice if
I've interfered in politics it won't be
the first time but at present we see the
danger we hear the messages from Mother
Nature we have the solutions they can be
implemented what's left to discuss
political will we need policies and our
current policies subsidize the burning
of fossil fuels worldwide at a rate 38
times larger than the meager
encouragement for the acceleration of
the sustainability revolution and of
course the fossil fuel companies and the
associated businesses and institutions
that have thrived along with them have a
tremendous amount of political power and
financial power will that determine the
outcome of humanity's future or will the
conscience of humanity have a role to
play we are seeing the rising generation
demanding a better world we are seeing
tremendous leadership from cities around
the world
Oslo will be the green capital of Europe
next year my congratulations to you mr.
mayor not only a name but with the
fantastic leadership Oslo has been
providing many regional governments the
state of California I mentioned earlier
has now committed itself legally to be a
zero carbon economy by 2045 Ireland has
just announced a complete divestment as
a nation of all fossil fuels and there
are many other examples corporations
particularly consumer-facing
corporations in the global economy are
shifting quickly to 100% renewable
energy and making other changes to be a
part of the solution instead of being
part of the problem but time is running
out some changes regrettably have
already occurred that will not be
recoverable but the truly catastrophic
changes that could end human
civilization as we presently know it can
still be avoided those who I most
respect in the scientific community and
you will see some of them in just a
moment agree on that point there are
uncertainties on the downside as well as
on the upside and most of the reports of
the last few decades have turned out in
retrospect to have been far too
conservative compared to the actual
events that have unfolded a global
emergency as I said at the beginning is
exactly what we confront but I will
close by
saying as I have in times past that for
those who feel the temptation to despair
remember how many great challenges have
been overcome in our history at moments
when advocates also felt despair when
the odds seemed piled up high against
success look over the list of awards
given here in Oslo and you will see the
names of champions who had moments when
they were certain they might be failing
but who overcame the obstacles and
always remember that political will is
itself a renewable resource thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]